one of the running themes of this
interview today has been a reference to
shirt record yeah quote-unquote broken
record and that is have more content you
always have more so even when you're in
a pitch you have more to show yeah what
does that entail for you how much is
more for you how many projects are we
talking about what do you have in your
quote arsenal so full arsenal full
arsenal I did an interview this is an
interview yeah I did an inventory
everything everything like everybody and
so I sort of did this experiment where I
mapped out everything and I thought ok
if I if I if every one of these things
got made like films pilots not counting
the length of how long the television
show would run but you know pilot gets
shot you know edited put on the air
picked up film shot put in theaters or
on stream or whatever like how long
would it take if everything in there and
there were no hiccups like you just got
it the money came in the buyers are
there the distribution was there just
did it like each piece without any
hiccups how long would it take to get
everything done I would have to be a
hundred and sixteen years old for
everything to get done that I've written
this year there's been a lot more focus
on television with the company and I'm
working with so there's only been one
feature one feature script that I wrote
this year but there's been
five pilots one of the pilots I've
written the first two seasons of the
show and the seasons are 10 episode
seasons another one the pilots have
written five episodes for this TV just
yeah just the TV
so five TV pilots complete two seasons
of completed scripts for one of the
pilots complete five episodes of another
of the TV pilots complete so for the
first one that's 20 scripts cuz there
are 10 episodes a season okay so there's
20 episodes of television plus five more
episodes of television plus the three
other pilots that I wrote I'm in the
process of writing one now and I'm
working on two other feature scripts
that are incomplete
that's summer - summer summer 18 summer
so and then there's just a ton of other
ideas that have been like jotted down
that are per later yeah mm-hmm do you
keep that in a file like do you have
like these idea files oh here okay don't
my phone and they have a notes thing on
your iPhone every time something pops up
from here to pull up the notes and then
I sit there with it then sometimes
sometimes are just crappy so I delete
them sometimes more stuff comes so I
write that stuff down and then sometimes
they turn into full-on scripts but yeah
constant constant constant constant
constant writing how do you know if you
were bored with a story or do you just
need more time with it I get bored
stories all the time so stop I and I
don't force anything like this seems
really cool okay this is cool oh this is
kind of dead that's that's not cool this
is a yeah yeah I start something else I
don't get rid of it I just put it down
and I start writing something else and
inevitably in writing something else an
idea will formulate that fixes this one
you know I'll like write something or
I'll be hanging out with someone or I'll
hear somebody say something I'm like
that would fix that other thing that I
stopped writing so I go back
that's all right no month and then when
that's done and go back to the other
thing and then while I'm working on that
somebody will say something or I'll see
something in the news it's constant it's
just constant constant creation
literally cut drive my wife nuts
constant creation and then if it fizzles
out
I don't fret about it I don't worry
about it
I don't struggle with it and oh my oh
how do I fit I just put away cuz there's
way more other stuff to be doing and
working on you know do you think the
mark of a professional is to continually
finish things sure probably
I mean you finish I finish I finished
more than I start but I am constantly
started it's not like I have like all
these unfinished screenplays you know
what I mean I tend to write fast like if
it comes to me it comes to me and so it
goes when that flow starts to like Peter
out I don't try to force it I just okay
it's petered out we're done for that and
then I want to the next thing they
always get finished but it's more about
for me it's more about flow it's not
flowing us know that because the thing
is you know people will say like oh you
should write this many pages a day right
you know this one or two scenes a day or
whatever it is but like you never know
where your head's gonna be you never
know where your creativity is gonna be
you never know what your Energy's gonna
be so if I'm like not in the best space
and I'm just like pushing through your
right stuff to like meet this like
requirement I'm just gonna write you
know crappy pages
I don't know write crappy pages you know
I want to have good pages so if that
means that on Tuesday I write two pages
dead I on Tuesday I write two pages if
on Thursday I write 15 pages dev on
Thursday I'm ranked 15 pages in font
Friday I just want to have a whiskey and
write no pages then I don't write no
pages but I don't beat myself up for
anything you know what I mean like
they're all there they're all constantly
all the characters
constantly like just bear living in my
head and so at a certain point one of
them will perk up be like hey you know
it would be cool if you did this
oh yeah it is cool I don't do that and
then sometimes I'll scrape the whole
thing and restart it cuz I came up with
something cooler same story same concept
but like a way better angle into it so
I've written the first act and I got 30
pages in something better came along I
can make those 30 pages even better
but I got a row 30 pages I have they go
alright new 30 pages have you ever
fallen in love with a character like
like fallen in love with a character
like like I want to leave my wife what
do you know no no that's you could still
fall in love with something doesn't mean
you have to change your life
an idea of something an idea of someone
most of them what's the point like if
you don't if you don't love it what's
the point of doing it you know I mean if
you're just writing the thing to write
the thing cuz you think you're gonna
sell this thing
I guess there's value in that if you've
got a goal and you're set for that but
for me man I this stuff I sell the stuff
I want to sell I love stuff I want to
make for myself I love the characters in
this thing I love the characters in the
movies I love the characters in the TV
shows I love I mean I you know I come up
with this TV show I wrote two seasons of
it throw two seasons twenty scripts mmm
madly in love with it
nobody asked me to do that I'm gonna
stop
you